[Applause]
george on a hard drive gets inside
sidestep missed
terence mann on the follow it's been a
man explosion here to start
and a timeout called by utah jumped on
him in the last game
missed shot mama there goes that man
wow
[Music]
nba conference semifinals jordan
clarkson he is capable of exploding
bad pass that time from conley rondo
throws it ahead batoon
alley up to man
parents man the throw down and the
clippers regain the lead
he's got 14 points already wide open
look from a
great three-point shooter reggie jackson
races up the floor
terrence mann wide open for three pucks
it in
terrence challenged reggie jackson i'm
not sure you can blame
rudy gobert reggie jackson's at the rim
panned down man up
[Music]
a solid offensive player this is more
than solid this is spectacular
jackson on the drive kicks it out for
man man three-pointer
[Applause]
george the drive back out batoon karen's
mann for three
over and over again man has gotten
terrific shots and
give the man credit
[Applause]
out to ron lou